we have not asked for this there was  never any agreement to take on the job  of supporting thousands of Asylum  Seekers this responsibility was simply  handed to us without warning as buses  began showing up  there's no playbook for this no  precedent no playlist we didn't want  these people we didn't invite these  people we didn't call our city a  sanctuary City for years and years and  years we didn't explicitly invite these  people I personally on Twitter and on  National Television oh wait a minute  just over a year ago you tweeted quote  New York City will remain a sanctuary  city under an Adams Administration what  is your message to migrants arriving in  the U.S should they still come to New  York City well I think that they should  come to any place in the country that  they desire of their pursuit of the  American dream ooh oops remember that  mayor Adams  never mind